welcome to this video round 3 coverage
of the Zurich chess challenge and yeah
unlike yesterday I'm actually doing this
video during a other normal time in the
evening and yeah I'm ready to present to
you three games there are only three
games in this tournament yeah to be
honest I much prefer to have those
bigger events but they may they tend to
nowadays limit the field to relatively
few players it saves money and gives
those record-breaking rating averages if
you invite ten players it's much harder
to get those high averages just a
mathematical normal too okay let's see
what happened today as we only have five
rounds in this tournament every game
counts for much and let's see what
happened today aronian Galfar this is
the first game i'm going to show and
galfar nowadays really goes for the
green felt his prep for the world
championship matches still alone is
still used and the role plays g3 which
surprises me a little bit um galfond had
played the sea 65 line before and he
lost against Magnus but Sir there's a
very solid line and it's at least my
book not are not too attractive to play
against that but okay aronian wants to
once to trial against this is 65 set up
and he comes up with the exchange and
Knight f3 going for the symmetrical line
now 95 yeah this is the only way you
relieved to try for a little bit in this
exchange line on
I really think white them should try
something yeah lesson simplifying like
queen bee three earlier or what Magnus
did with Queen a form but gawa aronian
went from went for this and Gavin now
plays an interesting move that I wasn't
really aware of that this is existing
the the normal way to play for black he
is actually something like this castles
93 and then black very often just place
ecigs and then challenges the night on
e5 this is believed to be quite okay for
black Gavin played a completely
different idea he played 94 just keeping
the symmetry and it seems that this is
yeah this is completely playable I'm
really surprised that this is even
existing and there are some pretty high
rated examples before that not on the
absolutely highest level but some
grandmasters have played the move
probably this is why I don't know it you
as a spectator you and in the lines you
don't play yourself regularly you mostly
know what the absolute top guys are
playing and they are never saw the move
yeah the idea is simply to do the same
with white is doing if a night pops up
on c6 on d 7 or here c3 and d2 it just
wants to you just wants to exchange it
this is also an idea of 95 the black
plays a move like 96 this type of trade
can get black into long-term problems
with the C porn at the c5 square 94-92
yeah I would like just rates this was
the idea yes of course lost some time
but the simplification is very welcome
and if you look at this no 97 it's very
difficult for y to even keep
yeah something on the board now when the
night is challenged and what should you
do it played not bishops III and it's
very difficult not to allow too many
traits i mean if you take for example
there's absolutely nothing going on it's
it's completely equal you know even a
move like green b3m attacking here yeah
black candy employee 6am but this is
also possible but this is even if this
is ok as this is also hanging down this
is just very dead and while you play
Bishop c3 and now girl from play Knight
f6 intending 94 again and simply this
type of position it does not have enough
bite for white to to get anything
anything substantial it's at best and
very miniscule edge and in the game we
see that after Queen B 394 yeah black is
intending to just take on c3 and get rid
of the bishops um yeah this provoked
wide to to take on e form try to get
some sort of imbalance going and it
didn't really it didn't really help much
rook deewani Edison's may be intending
d5 kawin b6 was played now and yeah what
would George should why do you don't
want to trade queens you don't really
have a great great square you can go to
a form and then black can if everything
else fails you can just take the night
off and put the bishop somewhere like
here and there's absolutely nothing
going on got opposite colored bishops
and well it's no endgame but it can
easily be even more simplified after
trades on the deef i'll note that one
idea for white could be
ecigs to open up the long diagonal
especially if the Queen can get somehow
involved in this it can get tricky but
in most cases after move like is six and
here is six is just not working at all
black can even play f6 so this is a
position without any ideas he traded on
b6 and continued with night see form
attacking this we can pawn but black in
fact does not really react to that in
plate this should be six simply because
white cannot take if he takes rookie six
mini can take but this is very simple
now the night does not have any squares
they are controlled so d5 needs to be
played and this leads to mass exchanges
like that and this is going to be a draw
yeah meaning white cannot take on b6
with any hope for an edge he played d5
which um yeah it's a bit more fighting
but at the end does not endanger black
too much it takes to hear no it took and
played King up 1 e 2 are saying so need
to react to that yeah this is a quite
quite interesting position at first I
thought when I looked at this I thought
that why it is really better because
well the pawn structure this looks weak
and this is also potentially week and we
can put a bit more on the board
something like that I thought them white
should should have something because of
the better pawn structure but black has
a very good maneuver and this is what
girlfriend played he played King f6 and
this is just very strong the king is
intending to join the game on me five
and this is very very important and the
Sun shows that
chess is really a game of dynamic give
imbalances sometimes White has the
better structure and it looks all nice
but he has 11 problem as well or a
disadvantage compared to blacks position
this is the King the king on everyone is
not really doing much and it takes some
moves to get into play if you play the F
porn for example you exchange of you
pawn on e4 I don't want that so how do
you activate it you need to go all the
way F 1 e 1 D 2 C 3 and so on and in the
meantime black can easily here activate
the King and even maybe start some play
against the d5 point at the point is
just protected by the night and can
easily be attacked further so this is a
very important defensive resource King
f6 to e5 activating the King and this
kind of ideas are often overlooked by
less experienced players because they
tend to yeah sometimes confuse the
middle game with the endgame in the
endgame the King really should play and
often can advance far up the board if
there's no specific threat against it to
join the battle and this is what black
is doing here it also leads to to this
idea define check so black needs to
cover that and it still has King e5
check Margie phone King f5 check and
back yeah in fact it is white who here
check first the draw the game ended
right here with the it's not a perpetual
check but it's a repetition of moves and
both sides really AM have no no way
forward here we look at this again check
this is what we had in the game um if
why it tries to to do anything um
to win you know I'm not quite sure what
it is or what it should be let's say you
place a move like H foyer just just for
argument's sake then blacks ideas to
play age 5 cover g form and now it gets
serious kingi five rocks is six and i'm
taking the bond and suddenly black as
the one to push forward and yeah this is
just the problem why it has no good way
to activate this night to join the
battle and do something against the pawn
on d6 or support the point on is X for
example so white cannot really play for
win but like also jack has little ideas
to to do to do more than go here and
secure the draw so fair result I think
only yeah I just think that this opening
is not ambitious enough you need to try
to keep a little bit more pieces on the
board however girl fans nighty for
Heroes may be a good good way to play em
if you just want to equalize completely
and maybe Aronian wasn't aware of this
this possibility or the consequences of
it and don't know ok next game let's
look at kawana against Arnaud am
changing the order of games he a bit
because frankly speaking this game this
round head one game that clearly stood
out and the two others were not not that
exciting and I'm doing the two less
exciting games first and be brief about
it and then concentrate on the on the
hit game of the round which obviously is
Nakamura against Carson okay Kara wanna
against Arnold V she has lost the first
two games so he really needs to get on
the scoreboard yeah kiwanis playing the
reti opening
and he's playing the the purity move
order with to see for a move order that
is in fact quite yeah quite interesting
for white and it would be one of my
preferred move for orders myself if I am
if I look at mail and tournament games
if it wasn't for the movie for which
always found slightly annoying because
black takes a space in the center and
they don't really like so much to play
benoni type of structure and this is my
problem with this this move order are
not however just played c6e didn't go
for d4 maybe am he's more focused on non
solid play here after two losses d for
is so much sharper okay koala is playing
d4 just transposase to a regular default
opening here wide of course has some
ways to try to benefit from not playing
deform like be three or III this is
interesting or g3 those ratty tag off
moves but d4 just goes to a regular
slough Bishop g4 yeah this one good line
after he three black has many many lines
that are similar in reputation or solid
Bishop f5 Bishop g4 sv she played on g6
they are good okay Bishop g4 and blacks
general plan in this slab structures of
course to get the bishop out of the
points chain and be solid in the center
g-form bishop g6 and cd5 this is a bit
uncommon this early trade usually white
starts with 95 in the serve in this
position and we'll get the bishop am the
compensation for the bishop parent for
blackest yeah it's not so apparent he's
got a very solid structure but still it
should be always a little some
thing if white grabs the bishops it
happens in the game as well that white
place 95 but only after the trade yeah
interestingly this she took with the
night this is a bit uncommon I'm not
saying in this exact position because
this position is not very much explored
but normally black recaptures with the
porn yeah it all makes sense though for
black he gets a rapid peace development
and yes as mentioned a very solid
structure and compensation for having
given up the bishop pal yeah g5 is a
good move the idea is to free the g6
square for night for example night at hg
69 to h4 and we see more of that in the
game another point of this is that it
looks at their foursquare what is
White's plan here White's plan is some
typically to play efore at some stage
gaining more space in the center and
then f4 would be a welcome square for
the night and this is what black is
trying to prepare you know here this
might get counter play now and again
looking at their four square so black is
playing a in anticipation of this e for
push now and Dwight covers a form so he
tries to renew the threat you know first
looking at b7 provoking a move and then
he fall yeah the same position is some
yeah somewhere between bit better for
white and indie qual he's got to play in
the center but black has got some
counter chances of course he goes to her
for as planned and after this straight
white played age 42
use this slightly shaky position of the
bishop on f4 black plate 35 yeah black
plate needs to play on the dark squares
they are this this is the area of the
board where has strength this and this
also makes sure that the bishop on g
tube is a bit of a silly piece your
whites response d5 the sir certainly
makes sense he wants to play on the
light squares if he takes only five
black can regain the porn easily and get
e5 later this is not so attractive I
think come on up lady five I think this
is the right decision 96 activating the
night and now he took on c6 yeah Black
has sacrificed the pawn temporarily but
it's no big deal ask up the check and
now castles yeah in s compensation for
the porn White has now taken the
compensation for the pawn is that like a
black we get this back under stone just
one porn down and the problem is rights
king is still in the middle of the board
therefore his rook is not playing at the
bishop results a week black will
certainly get some play on the Kings
side as compensation and what white is
doing now i think is very sensible but
it returns the pawn quite quite quickly
it's difficult to ya to not do that i
mean what should why do let's say if he
takes just for example black takes here
Queen back may be here then rook e8 for
example yeah right now has 12 points but
how do you continue here got weak pieces
week squares and be two eggs and it's
very difficult to keep the cornea even
and widest in big trouble
what Kara wanna this is very sensible he
played 95 which is some getting the
Queen's off now he played before using
his own majority two against one he am
yeah age for hangs but what what should
he do he could have played h5 this would
have been an alternative but after night
h4 it's not so clear what why should do
I mean black will get be to back this is
essentially a double attack and yeah
it's not great if white takes here and
something like this this is look so like
playing for a loss very a very ugly yeah
I think before I some very very decent
move and now black regained the porn on
h4 and I think this is finely balanced
white has display with the two against
one Paul well black has the h4 pond and
this nicely positioned bishop put
irritates white yeah after a couple of
more moves you know white played there
very useful regrouping activating the
bishop yeah this is an excellent square
so why it needs to prevent that on 96
now you would of course just you could
just just take it yeah this is what
happened to you and they repeated quite
a lot lots of times and here they agreed
to a draw yeah it's a very hard for both
sides to make any substantial progress
iam it's especially if you look at this
how is white ever going to play b5 with
black controlling the C file it's very
difficult
so I think a very fair result with the
draw solid play by by vision karana
didn't really get anywhere near um and
me an advantage in this game so it's a
good for him for a fava she to have
stopped the losing streak of two games
okay now we go for the the main cause of
of this this round Nakamura against
Garza yeah of course if you know the
history between the two players they
have played um quite a number of
tournament games of course already and
Carlton has an overwhelming scoff I
think eight wins no loss and of course a
couple of drawers Nakamura has never won
a single classical time control game
against Garza but with the cameras
admissions and now being number three in
the world or sort of hovering between 34
he certainly should yeah get a win some
somewhere against Magnus so let's see
what what happens yet also note that
this is of course paramount for the
tournament standings as both players
have won one game drone jun 1 so if this
would have an decisive results the
winner would have excellent chance of
winning the tournament the camera
playing d for good choice no Berlin and
we come to see the limbs oh yeah in
general I think that playing the white
side of the NIMS Oh is a very good a
good fighting choice if you play deform
and just like an island it in Game nine
of the World Championship match where he
came close to to do something against
cousin and then he blundered with it was
what i was looking for i think where he
gave away the sad repair for yeah well
it was a very very sharp game and it was
this f3 move and this is Nakamura plays
here as well and also just a coincidence
what I recommended back in 2011 in my
small D for repertoire video series as
some a good way to fight for white yeah
3 is some very straight forward move it
addresses the main point of the NIMS oh
that you foursquare controlling it with
the pawn and yeah why does certainly
eager to get reform in here getting a
big porn center cousin is playing d5 the
most solid response that immediately
gets some space in the center a 3 and
here he played a surprising move I'm
normally every top layer here just
captured and place a c5 and this is also
what was played in the World
Championship match game after CD
five-carbon played ed5 also a surprise
and the in this match game 95 being the
old alma main line but this is the the
main battleground of the any of the f3
nims Oh what cars are now plays Bishop
e7 really has slightly dodgy reputation
I mean in the postgame press conference
Carlton said something like yeah and you
wear this is a bit risky this line I
thought I have some counter chance and
so on well we see that the idea
connected to this is indeed risky after
you for which nakamura played um like is
taking on e4 and place a 5 this is the
idea behind this Bishop e7 retreat black
immediately wants to get this counter
play with e5 and sort of forces whites
to play d5 yeah of course you cannot
really take care it's ruining your pawn
structure of
something like that yeah you will
probably get it back rather quickly
Saudi five anyway is the idea and this
of course secures white some nice space
advantage in the center blacks idea is
to play that activating this bishop okay
it is moving again but it will get an
interesting post on the forum and black
has some good piece control over the
dark squares however the reason why all
this is risky is that why it still has
the space advantage in the center it
very quickly we see that very quickly
after some normal moves really yeah I'm
not sure about Bishop g4 I'm taking but
they wanted to address this position we
see that black indeed will manage to get
a piece on deform this is nice but what
is this is what is blacks plan after
that it's nice to have it on d4 and we
see that just to put it on the wall he
played it it's nice to have this on your
form but what is your concrete way
forward this black white has a very
straightforward plan and a camera is
playing simply those moves c5 and now he
goes g49 to g3 now this is a wrong arrow
night to g3 developed the bishop and
then maybe h4 g5 just push everything on
the Kings side and where exactly is
blacks counterplay it's it's not so
clear to me what black is doing against
that we see that he tries a five Andruw
a six and put this on the board you know
this g6 also debatable but this is
blacks idea he wants to play against b2
and generate some counter play but this
is rather easily covered and after
that white has a very simple
straightforward play on the Kings side I
to be honest I just thought that this is
very rare head opening for black this
this looks really nice on before I
understand but isn't White's play and
yeah it is quite obvious so in a camera
does not really need to do anything to
specially and gets a fantastic position
let's see what happened yeah g6 not to
move your love to play but do you want
the night on f5 certainly not so g6 not
not very laughs not a happy move but
night f5 also would have been very very
difficult to to defend yeah this is
fairly NADRA Karuk h2 is a strong move
it covers be too and also prepares the
further doubling on the edge far so good
move to combine the tech and defense
Queen a 5 yeah I think that this is the
idea he wants to move the f6 night and
you cannot do that while you're pinned
should be to back to c7 and now g5 and
age 5 so very easy play from that camp
where I just needed to push the Kings
side and after rock v6 here's another
important point I think for for a strong
player the next movies is quite obvious
but situations like that tend to be very
tricky for for amateur players if you
look at this position what should why do
he has a very obvious move what's this
Bishop f5 and how to assess this
position yeah I think a strong player
quite quickly comes to the conclusion
that Bishop f5 winning the exchange is
really not worth it because rook takes
me to check this possible for black rook
takes and Queen a 5
and you notice that it's no big deal for
black to have given up the exchange you
still have this Bishop here and it feels
like black has gained something white
skiing is more more of a problem now and
white cannot so easily push the pieces
over to the Kings side to attack it just
slows down why the tech nakamura played
Bishop c1 and this is just much much
stronger I mean it's not a not a
world-class movement I think a good
master player would do that as well but
it's very very important to to not cash
into Ernie sometimes Bishop f5 is just
selling your position too cheaply you
only get this exchange for porn this is
stop not good enough in this position
why it should seek to try to checkmate
black or really gained substantial
material and not like half a pawn let's
say yeah rook be three this is some the
only active piece that black has
combined with the bishop Quincy form and
Knight b6 ya black ass trying form for
some sort of counter play against c4 and
also allowing to use the Queen to switch
over to the King side he also could have
tried a 96 but the the real issue is
white has a simple attacking plan the
bishop moves it goes to c2 and rook to
h1 and if black has no defense it's
sometimes really an interesting
phenomenon if you have such a nice
Bishop on on deform it just it just
defend or less for the King let's say
black would very much in this position
probably prefer to have this Bishop on
g7 it's just it sounds weird but it
would help to protect
King it will still be a bad position for
black but it would be helpful in defense
while here on d4 it's not helping at all
to defend yeah let's mention 96 Bishop
d3 it's not it's not helping much
something like that is its unbearable
for black I mean here you can also win
the exchange probably because the rich
reedus is also very very poor yeah this
is what was played and now there should
be two no this is the simple plan double
on the edge file yeah blacks position is
super critical what he tried to do is I
think very human he wants to have some
sort of counter play we went night oops
wrong button when tonight to g6
counter-attacking on c4 and yeah we're
just hoping that it's it's not an
immediate made rook edge one very
obvious smooth however there were
alternatives a good alternative was to
just take on g 6 p.m. the idea is that
after the capture which is probably the
move that black will play you can give
this check here check King edge eight
and now look H 1 this is also very
strong for white the point is that after
Luke takes him check check after all
this there is a double attack those two
pieces and lose this is also very strong
Nakamura he is in a position where he
can play many moves that that probably
win this is one of them and then he
played it yeah colonists of course
looking for counter play and there's
it's time for desperate measures he took
on be too
yeah this is not objectively a great or
anything but the only way to to get some
kind of play why took it and takes on c4
he wants to activate is remaining pieces
to the maximum Bishop takes Knight eggs
now so like a sacrifice the piece to
have some play against the king at least
is only idea to improve further is Queen
B 6 and we see that well this is this is
coming shortly yeah what is White's best
move it's a simple one to take on g6
like a more also went for that and now
of course Carlton is not recapturing on
g6 if you would take here for example
you just have this check and after King
edge aged white can you take on g 6 cm
and it collapses on h7 the unguent that
after rook takes rook takes there are
two rooks on the h1 so no problem at all
of course Carlin's idea was different he
went queen bee six the only way
absolutely only way to get some sort of
counter play and yeah it hangs on b2 now
and what should why do yeah it's in fact
a case again where more than one move is
probably winning what na cameras playing
assume is ok but there were also
alternatives and straightforward once he
also could have taken on f7 THX an
interesting move if black recaptures the
night h5 attending this check and hmm
it's very difficult now to see a defense
after it takes riders of course not
taking to get me to just place King a1
and yeah I really don't see a defense
also note that Quincy
a check is coming yeah probably this was
winning as well what he did g7 is also
winning but it's a it needs to be
precisely followed upon okay of course
simple one black cannot take him this is
all this one it's only made like this
check checkmate leading to a mid black
cannot take he played rock the aid of
course you can ask what happens after
this white is playing King a1 and after
that he needs to address this hanging
rook probably with rock d eight leading
to the game yeah in the game he played
rook 28 first and after Queen age for
each one on be too yeah this looks wild
but it's it's perfectly okay for white
this happened and now Queen here night
f5 or all completely completely obvious
but note that by now y term no white has
gotten five pawns like a Scott six porn
so why did support down but okay Fitz
it's obvious he has a very strong attack
but now you need to be precise IAM now
night is having a threatened so like how
was that and here in this position the
the question is how to how to continue
and nakamura he had had a very concrete
chance to win the game and um he didn't
find it it's an interesting position to
to analyze yourself not with the
computer preferably try to do it like in
a regular game it's interesting to to to
to find the the best movie m it seems
that the best movie is I mean them there
than one that's more than one good news
I think the most powerful year's Queen
f2 this has a very strong threat but
it's not a very typical threat so not so
easy to to spot white thread is Luke
takes h7 it this is very strong if black
plays I should probably just play it out
if if black plays a move like that yeah
then rook takes h7 is coming the easy
line is of course King takes we can
start with that check leading to a
direct mate on edge it checkmate now
this was too much so we need to look at
Queen takes and after that of course
right h6 is coming after that check
check check check check mate it's a long
line but it's a correct one winning with
the checkmate so black yeah has no
choice he needs to give up the Queen iam
and yeah this is of course completely
winning for white it's not just the
queen is also Queen here the deep on
it's too much it's just too much like
will lose the shortly compass on + 10
Queen edge fall off to f2 this was a
very direct way to win but rook takes H
tetanus not the is the motif that is not
so easy to spot he played Queen g4 which
does not spoil anything threatening rook
h6 black needs to react to that plate
Queen B 6 so that i Luke h6 you have
queen bee to mate we went back Queen g6
and if he didn't he was looking for the
win but he didn't find it may be here I
didn't analyze that but Justin what
about Queen everyone here just
about that this may be winning as well
with the same idea I didn't look at this
but maybe this is winning as well let's
say b5 and if you take on age 7 now
there isn't this wedding yeah it is
winning it's just the same just the same
I had switched on the comp just to be
sure to not tell any nonsense yeah this
is also winning so he it seems that he
absolutely didn't spot the rook takes h7
idea which is really finishing the game
off maybe this was too quick they
repeated a while and here again after
let's say queen age for Queen f1 it's
it's just winning instead of that he
played d6 and it seems that this is a
really substantial mistake it's a it's
basically winning a piece but it's not
it's not winning the game this is some
the issue black takes white eggs and of
course black cannot take on d6 because
of the medium checkmate so look the
eighth and now black has activated this
is the crazy crazy fact the rook now is
on an open file and yeah what should do
I do he played the night to see for this
was the intention all along and what
else I mean he could have gone to f5
this is also possible a team but look at
this check check check
check check check mate and suddenly
white is mated night f5 is just ignite
neglected neglecting neglecting the e6
square this is why I went to see four
but now after Queen takes black suddenly
has some some real counterplay Queenie
one check rook do you wanna check and
note that white skin is not to secure in
addition of course this night is hanging
okay there's a maid thread on age seven
so black is not immediately threatening
to take it but the night has absolutely
no secure square anymore it had an
excellent post on f5 protected by the
for porn but now the night is just yeah
it doesn't have secure operating base
anymore and here we are move 40 the
notorious move 40 the last move before
the time control and nakamura now needs
to take an important decision what to
play here d 1 is the threat rook t1 as
the thread and they're basically two
moves to to address this issue 93 and
queen age five he went for Queen age
five and it turns out that this move was
losing the game as hard as it is he had
to totally winning position five moves
ago and now after Queen age five it is
even losing it seems that I'll show you
why but it seems that night III instead
would have secured the draw it's of
course very difficult to assess this
with limited time the computer has just
merciless just 000 but while we're not
computers and to be honest I didn't
follow the game life today I was
5th most ly sleeping the whole day hmm
but when I when I went through this and
I saw that he spoiled this completely
winning position it's it's quite usually
you lose their you don't even draw after
you spawn such a big advantage you have
you find ways to even deuce simply
because he was certainly aware that he
had a totally winning position and maybe
even saw some winning line and played
another one because they thought okay
this wins as well and then oh it's not
winning well this is bad you simply
don't have the psychological strength to
UM to to get to fight to a draw at least
ninety nine point nine percent of the
players don't and here 93 it seems would
have drawn but it's not easy at all to
to see all that Queen d3 for example is
a move that looks very threatening here
for example queens III but it seems that
night f5 is securing a draw it's a bit
strange this type of back and forth but
there's only one heaviest piece that can
invade on the default and it's better to
have the Queen there than the route
coming in here there's this is really
only a draw something like this is a
perpetual but why is this such a mistake
the problem is that Carlton now has rook
to e3 and he finds it this is this is
the amazing thing about this guy if you
give him a chance really concrete chance
he would take it absolutely you would
take it I mean it was completely busted
and now there's the point is on to also
only this move wins every other move was
just drawing or losing he needs to play
exactly that move and he does and yeah
what is so strong about it the point is
is just be five white really lacks a
good move in this position and blacks
next move will be b5 and if this night
moves again a three faults and
the White King is just it's just hunted
down it's just terrible white what
should why do now you only have this
threat against age 7 and you cannot
strengthen your attack in any way you
play grew gauge form attacking the Queen
end the same way also covering the night
and black just retreated to f5 keeping
this threat in the position yeah Queenie
to you need to cover that right here
Carlton had term and I implied that
sorry b5 was played attacking the knight
and retreated here I was referring to
this position here he had a very
comfortable choice between between two
moves rook takes a three he also could
have played King moves and somewhere
let's say here and black s also when
excellent shape note that yes four pawns
already for the for the night and those
two pawns are a doomed and it's the king
of the king is just totally insecure
it's a quadrant marker will help save
black blacks king is this is a typical
case where the white pawn on g7 is not
helping at all why'd I mean just a nicer
nice pawn to to cover cover black yeah
this was very strong for blood this one
he decided to play Queen g5 and this is
just as strong it has the benefit that
drugs off and this some maybe makes it
simpler to play now this is a tech this
is a text so we have only this sequence
and now we basically have an end game
with it big big amount of bones yeah
this is also gone of course yeah here
95 check naka washa fail to that losing
the night on the Queen trade chat and
the Queen traders of course also lost
combined force of the H porn and
potentially the a porn is this is too
much for the night of the night is the
absolutely lease term suitable piece to
stop stop horns especially those flank
bones it's just completely lost so
couldn't take on c5 yeah and here Carson
is just mercilessly hang winning this
game pushing the pawns it's it's no easy
you just need to make sure you don't
blend the 222 summit echo on to some fog
like it's just pushing pawns H pawn
bpong check yeah he was giving that away
but you have we have the h-bomb this is
the the main point now also this it's an
overload and now threatening to promote
yeah the hip lots of pawns I didn't even
look at this final phase of the game
yeah this is how it went check and here
here Nakamura resigned after black cover
to the seven square so after Kim move
you can promote and white does not leave
never meaningful Czechia so an
absolutely devastating loss for Nakamura
who had a completely winning position
and deservedly should have won because
our cards and set up in the opening was
really dubious and
it should have cost him the game yeah
but here it's bad exactly here he didn't
find the concrete way concrete way to
win with the Queen f2 Luke h7 this is
the the clearest way maybe there are
more i mean i'm pretty sure that there's
more than one way to win the game um
trying to figure out something else him
there's something else between Queen f2
besides Queen have to rock age six would
be very nice to get played but black
always plays Queen Queen to be 6m yeah
well I don't I don't you well you only
need one win foot just trying to find
something else yeah well ok it's a it's
a game that shows that you really need
to to take your chances if you have such
a brilliant position you need to you
need to really finish it off and Carson
is absolutely merciless and exploiting
those situations where the opponent is
not playing the absolute killer move and
letting him back into the game and it's
amazing that that you want this I mean
it's more do tuna cameras failure let's
say then 22 cards and credit but it
happens so often that it is it is no
coincidence he's winning position that
you really shouldn't win often it's a
yeah it's it's also it's very very tough
defense playing the only moves and by
now it's also a thought of soup
psychological thing of course people
really get get scared of his abilities
and especially Nakamura with this
terrible score I mean I really I really
think that Nakamura on a good day he
would find moves like Queen f tune rook
h7 in a bullet game really I think he's
so good at tactics and I really don't
know maybe maybe around here he was
already
second-guessing himself if he had
spoiled something before yeah maybe I
should have done this should have done
that was this the best way to play and
so on him you don't know I mean maybe he
did really um yeah maybe he thought he
already had sports something it's it's
difficult difficult to say um okay a
very important game of course for this
tournament now cards and leading with
two wins and two wins out of five games
is already already quite substantial
very lucky of course and I can where I
should have one here but yeah let's
let's let the game of chess it's a
matter of matter of mistakes and
exploiting them and it's not only about
getting good positions out of the
opening or something cars very often
shows that you can win even without
without out of bed positions alright
thanks for watching I hope you've
enjoyed it I'll be back I guess tomorrow
right tomorrow should be round four yeah
I'll be back for round for the
regardless of it is tomorrow or whatever
thanks for watching